The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so let's get started.
So today-- our last lecture we
talked about different device
parameters, mainly
our series resistance
and shunt resistance, and how
that affects our efficiencies.
Today we're going to talk a
lot about different material
properties and how they affect
certain device characteristics,
and mainly just affect
our output efficiency.
So we've been talking a
lot about the fundamentals.
I'm sure you guys are
loving this right now.
So we're going to complete
this in probably the next three
lectures and then
move on to a lot
of the kind of
cross cutting themes
in PV-- some advanced concepts,
different device architectures,
and that kind of thing.
And so that is
coming in the future,
but we're still doing
fundamentals today.
And so I know you're probably
all aware of this equation.
And again, this is kind
the progress we've made,
so we're almost all the way
through explaining basic device
physics and basic
semiconductor physics so you
can understand simple devices.
And it's always important to
remember that your device is
like a leaky bucket, and
you're limited by the largest
hole in that bucket.
So the weakest aspect
of your solar cell
is really what's going to
limit your device performance,
and especially if
any of you here
are trying to make devices,
it's really important
to think about all of these
things when building it.
And this is very
difficult to do.
I can certainly tell you that.
So I kind of like this slide.
What this is saying
what's the thing we care
about most in our solar cells?
Well, as scientists, other
than dollars per watt,
we want to maximize our
efficiency for a certain price.
And our efficiency,
there's several parameters
that go into it.
Again, we talked about our
GSC, our short circuit current,
our open circuit voltage,
and our fill factor.
And that gives our output
energy, or output power,
and we divide that
by the input power,
which is the solar insulation.
Now we can split up that
again into open circuit
voltage, short circuit
current, and fill factor.
We talked a little bit last
lecture about fill factor
and how that's influenced
by different resistive
losses in our solar cell.
Today we're going to mainly
be focused on short circuit
current and things like internal
quantum efficiency, which
are highly affected by
our diffusion length.
And the diffusion
length is often
limited by certain
defects in our materials,
and we're going to
get into why that is.
And to a certain extent,
we'll talk about open circuit
voltage, because your GSC
really has a large effect
on your open circuit voltage.
So what we're going
to learn today
is what is minority
carrier diffusion length.
It was in the homework.
Hopefully you guys have
some idea coming to lecture,
but today we're going
to talk about it
a little more in depth,
and why it's important,
and how it's affected.
What are the parameters
of determinants?
So mainly diffusivity
and lifetime.
We're going to describe
how it's actually
measured in a solar
cell, which is actually
a really cool measurement,
and we actually
have the capabilities
in our lab.
And possibly some of you,
when you're making cells,
will be able to do
that measurement.
We're also going to look
at some of the things that
limit lifetime, some of the
basic recombination mechanisms.
Also look at how your excess
carrier concentration changes
as a function of lifetime
and generationally.
And then also talk about
the last material parameter,
which is mobility,
which discusses
of how well these excited
charges can move around
in your material.
So without further ado,
here are minority curve,
diffusion length.
The definition is really simple.
If you generate--
let's say, a photon
comes in and hits a silicon atom
and generates an electron pair
over here.
How far or how much
volume can it explore?
And that volume
it can explore is
described by some
characteristic radius,
and that radius is known
as the diffusion length.
And it's really
important to solar cells,
because when you think
about these carriers
that you're generating.
If they can only explore
a very short area,
they're not going to make it.
This is a very good solar
cell, so the diffusion length
is really long, and
all these carriers
that are just
generated there will
be able to make our junction.
So again, just so we're
familiar, this is our base.
In the top, we have our emitter.
So the junction would be at this
line right here on that plane.
If we have a really
bad solar cell--
so let's say a lot
of defects present,
a lot of areas for these excited
carriers to recombine-- they
won't make it to the junction.
They'll have a very
short diffusion length,
and as a result, your short
circuit current and your VOC
will suffer dramatically.
So it's really important
to get good crystal quality
and good material quality,
but up to a certain point.
There's kind of
diminishing returns
as you go to higher
and higher qualities,
so we'll talk about
that in a second.
So if we assume--
what this is showing
is how our short circuit current
scales with our diffusion
length.
So we have something
called the generation rate,
and this is often
proportional to the photon
flux on your material.
So the number of photons
hitting your solar cell.
And this generation
rate is something--
the number of carriers produced
per second in some given
volume.
So it's a volumetric term.
And if we assume that
everything within one diffusion
length of our junction
gets collected,
that'll all be counted
as short circuit current.
So basically your
JSC has this kind
of linear dependence on
your diffusion length,
but that's only true
up to a certain point.
So for example, if we
have a diffusion length
that is much longer than
the device thickness.
It's really not going
to be-- you get, again,
diminishing returns as you go
to longer and longer diffusion
lengths.
So this is a calculation I
did using a 1D simulation
program called PC1D, which if
you want to play around with,
it's free.
It's a lot of fun
to use, actually,
and you can put in
things like lifetimes--
and very basically,
the lifetime, which
we'll get to in a second--
how that changes the diffusion
length.
And you can see that there
actually is a linear relation
until the diffusion length
is about on the order of 300
microns, which is
the device thickness.
So you can see this
kind of trailing often
and become sub linear
in its response.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you clarify
why when the minority carrier
flux at the edge of
the space charge region
matters, because
I'm thinking about
there's the back contact
and the front contact,
and there's a junction right
near the front project.
They're not
[INAUDIBLE] connecting.
PROFESSOR: So let's think
about it one step back.
Why do we care about
minority carriers?
AUDIENCE: Because those are
the ones that are actually
generating the current.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
if, let's say, you
generate an electron hole
pair and n-type material,
the hole wants to move
to the p-type side.
And the electric field will
actually repel and keep
the electron on the n-type side.
So it's your minority
carriers the matter
in terms of the
separation, and we'll
talk about that again if that's
still fuzzy in people's heads.
And so what matters
in terms of-- you're
talking about deriving
the ideal diode equation?
AUDIENCE: Well, no. [INAUDIBLE].
So it seems like the important
thing is that some carrier gets
to the metallization?
PROFESSOR: Well,
yeah, but in order
to be separated, which is the
first part that we care about,
it matters that it's
reached the junction.
And so it's that concentration
at the junction that determines
the flux across the junction.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And so there's also
this other loose dependence
on VOC on your diffusion length.
And so if you recall
from a few lectures ago,
this is your equation for VOC.
It's dependent on your short
circuit current, temperature,
and your saturation current,
which you can often think also
think of as your
reverse bias current.
And your saturation current
is dependent on your diffusion
length.
JSC, if you recall, was
linearly proportional
to the diffusion length,
so the VOC actually
scales with the natural log
of the square of the diffusion
length.
And if you pull
out that exponent,
it just squares with the natural
log of your diffusion length.
And again, very,
very simple analogy--
we're assuming, again, that fill
factor is not really affected
by your diffusion length
and that your efficiency is
proportional to the product
of your JSC and your VOC,
so your short circuit current
and your open circuit voltage.
And you can see as go to
longer diffusion lengths,
there's this area of
diminishing return.
And again, there's two
different regimes here.
One is when your diffusion
length is, again, much less
than your device thickness.
You can see that there's a
huge increase in efficiency,
but as your diffusion
length gets well,
well above your
device thickness,
it becomes less
and less important.
So how do you deal with this?
So if you have,
let's say-- suppose
you want to make a
really cheap solar cell,
and you have a
very dirty material
with very short
lifetime shown here.
There's several ideas
of what you can do.
You can have a very,
very thin device.
Now, that's a problem if you
can't absorb it very well.
So you can have
some optical tricks.
You can do surface texturing.
There's all sorts of other
ideas for basically having
the carriers coming
in at angles or having
a good reflector on the back.
So that's ways you can work
with very low diffusion length
materials and still get a device
efficiency that's not too bad.
Now we're going to talk quickly
about how our minority carrier
diffusion length is
measured, and again, this
is something we're
able to do in our lab.
And one of the important
things to say is defined
is collection probability.
So for example, if
this is our junction
right here-- so our
space charge region--
if you generate a carrier,
let's say very, very close
to the junction, it's going
to have a high or near unity
probability of making it to the
junction and being collected.
If it's generated very,
very, very far away,
it's going to have
a lower probability.
And that's what
this graph is trying
to show-- is that right near
the junction you have near unity
collection probability, and
as you go way, it comes down.
And the different
colored lines are
showing different ways of
increasing that diffusion
length.
Service passivation
is important.
We'll talk about
what that is soon.
And also diffusion
lengths-- if you're
limited by diffusion
length, you can see
this very, very sharp drop off.
AUDIENCE: Just a follow up.
So is collection meaning
collected by the front contact
to be used in your
external circuit?
PROFESSOR: Mm-hm.
Right here it's
technically defined
as reaching the junction
and being separated,
which, in essence, will
hopefully be the same thing.
AUDIENCE: So is surface
passivation [INAUDIBLE]
sort of like diffusion?
PROFESSOR: It can affect
the diffusion length,
and we'll-- or the affect
of diffusion length.
We'll to that in a second.
It'll be a bit later.
This is kind of just
showing that there's
a lot of different
material parameters--
not just your diffusion
length-- that can really
affect your device performance
and your collection
probability.
So if you recall
a few slides back,
we said that our
short circuit current
is directly proportional
to our diffusion length.
And the reason is that, if
you're generating carriers
within the diffusion
length, you generally
think of that as the region
of which you're actually
collecting those carriers.
And if you go back to the
next slide, that kind of makes
sense.
So this is highlighted.
So this is our junction here.
We have our n-type material
on top, our p-type below.
And within a diffusion length
of your minority carrier--
so on your p-type type side you
care about the diffusion length
of your electrons.
On the n-type side, you care
about the diffusion length
of your holes, and that's the
region where you're really
collecting carriers.
Of course, there's a tail
off, but the first order
approximation-- this is
actually a very good one.
And so now putting
those all together.
If we know how our
carriers are generated
as a function of x, and we what
the collection probability is
as a function of x based on
diffusion length, surface
passivation, and
other parameters,
we can multiply them
and then integrate
to actually get what our
illuminated current will be.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have like three regimes
because the diffusivities are
different at each [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The emitter?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the junction afterwards?
PROFESSOR: Mm-hm.
For most models you
pretty much assume
that anything
absorbed-- first of all,
the space charge region
is very, very narrow.
It's almost assumed just
to be negligibly thin.
And the emitter is
generally very, very short,
and the diffusion lengths are so
poor in the emitter for reasons
we'll get to soon that
it's almost a dead layer.
Your response, the
very short wavelengths,
where you're absorbing most
of your light and emitter
generally don't add to
your short circuit current,
and we'll talk about that soon.
So excellent question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that first
region right there--
PROFESSOR: Wait, sorry.
Say that again.
I couldn't--
AUDIENCE: People just
approximate the first region
there and not care about
[INAUDIBLE] afterwards?
PROFESSOR: So for certain
wavelengths of light,
let's say, that
are-- this curve,
this is kind of representing
Beer Lambert's law.
If it attenuates
less drastically,
that characteristic
absorption length,
if it's a lot longer than
this length here, then yes.
You can assume that this emitter
region is negligibly thin,
and that's a little bit
what the homework goes over
as well in problem three.
Excellent question.
And so what we care about
is the spectral response
of our short circuit current.
So what this is is this a
quantum efficiency tool.
This is something
we have in our lab.
It's a really fun tool
to play around with.
How it works is you
basically have--
we have a light source
that's white light,
and it goes through
a series of filters.
There's a monochromator,
which basically-- it
diffracts the light,
so it spatially
separates the light,
kind of like a rainbow.
And then you can focus
that onto your solar cell
and measure the current output
under short circuit conditions.
And that will tell you-- because
you know the carrier generation
profile for different
wavelengths of light,
because you know what
alpha is for silicon,
you can actually
pretty well calculate
what your diffusion
length is, and we'll
talk about on the next slide.
So this is kind of what
your quantum efficiency will
look like.
This is, I think--
I actually don't
know if this
internal or external,
but they're just related
by a factor of 1 over r.
So here you're blue
response-- so everything
that's absorbed right in
the near surface region
in your emitter generally
doesn't get collected,
and this is due to
really bad diffusion
lengths in the emitter region.
As you go to longer wavelengths,
the absorption length
is much, much deeper.
You're collecting a lot of
it, and then what do you think
is happening here?
Generally these longer
wavelengths-- your alpha
is so low that
you're not actually
absorbing much of
this light, which
is part of the reason that
you're not collecting it,
or that you're absorbing it
so far away from the junction
that it's not being
able to diffuse there.
And so that's kind
of how you can
look at these quantum
efficiency curves,
and it's this region
here that's really
limited by diffusion length.
And again, you have
a homework problem
discussing how that's done.
Some of the cool other tools--
the lab can kind of do this,
but it requires a little
more-- I don't know--
hand work on the operator.
But if you can take
different EQE or I IQE
curves at different
points on your solar cell
and you get those
spectrums, you'll
get a whole bunch of
different spectrums.
You'll scan with
your light beam.
You can actually get
diffusion lengths
as a function of
position and get
a spatial map of your
different diffusion lengths.
And it's really
helpful if you're
trying to fine spatial
inhomogeneities in your cell.
So I believe that this is
some multi-crystalline cell,
and see all sorts
of grain boundaries.
And those are areas of very
short diffusion length,
and we'll talk about why
that's the case, actually,
on the next couple slides.
Question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you just
clarify the difference
between diffusion length,
absorption length, and band
depth energy?
Because I thought that the
middle weight ones were more
absorbed because they were bent?
Their higher weight [INAUDIBLE]
for bigger-- to cross
bigger band depth energies.
I didn't think it was because
of the absorption [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So alpha is what
tells you is your absorption
coefficient, and it's often in
units of one over centimeters,
so inverse centimeters.
And so if you plot
what that looks like,
it's an exponential
function with x.
And the point to
which it is attenuated
by a factor of one over e,
that point is 1 over alpha.
And that's often called
the absorption depth
or-- what am I thinking of?
Absorption length
of that wavelength.
And alpha will vary as a
function of wavelength.
If you recall that, if you
look at lambda, for silicon,
it's something that continues to
go down at longer wavelengths.
So the short wavelengths
are absorbed very strongly,
and so most of the light is
absorbed very, very close
to the surface, where the longer
wavelengths-- most of the light
is actually absorbed rather
far from the surface.
Does that make sense?
And so there's a difference
between your absorption length
and your diffusion
length, and that ratio
is what's really important.
If you're absorbing really
far away from the junction,
but you have a long
diffusion length,
there's a greater chance
of it making there.
And it's that ratio that's
really, really important.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So what limits this minority
carrier diffusion length?
We're going to get
to the equation
in a second for the minority
carrier diffusion length,
but basically when you
excite an electron hole pair,
you have this mobile electron,
and it's in this excited state.
You've given it this
energy from a photon,
and now it can move
around, and it can only
exist for a certain
amount of time
before it finds another
whole and recombines.
And that event, again,
is called recombination.
And a lot of this is actually
determined by the size
of grains in your material.
If you've seen-- I
think on the cell
that [INAUDIBLE] brought
in earlier-- sorry
I don't have a good
example-- it didn't just look
like one kind of flat plane.
You could see different
grain orientations,
and the edges of those grains
are called grain boundaries,
and those can act as
recombination centers
and actually reduce
your-- it's called
your lifetime, which we're
going to get to on this slide.
So this slide has a
lot of stuff going on.
What it's saying is that
your diffusion length
is characteristic
of the diffusivity--
the square root of the
product of your diffusivity
in your lifetime.
The way I like to
think of diffusivity
is that it goes up
with temperature,
and it's also affected
by your mobility.
The mobility is saying
that, if you apply,
let's say, an external
field, and electric field,
how well can those
electrons move around?
So a really high mobility
means that those electrons can
move really easily, and you'll
accelerate them really quickly,
where very low
mobility means they're
going to continue
to hit into things,
and bump around, and not
move around too well.
And your diffusion is this
kind of thermal process.
If you think of, let's
say, gases in a room,
and you have a hot gas, that's
going to diffuse a lot faster.
So it's the product
of these two things.
It's how well it can
move around times
it's thermal energy that
it has to move around,
the energy it has for moving.
And so that's kind of what
the diffusivity means to me.
The lifetime, again,
is what I mentioned
earlier-- is that when
you create this excited
electron that's now free to
move, this mobile electron,
it can move around and explore
a certain area, that area.
Volume is defined by
the diffusion length.
And it exists in that excited
state for some amount of time,
tau, and that tau is not--
not every carrier that
is generated necessarily
has that lifetime,
but it's a characteristic
lifetime that it could have.
And then they're pointed
out here what they are.
So that's what affects
our diffusion length.
So in the next bunch
of slides, we're
going to talk about mainly
how we can affect tau.
So tau is mainly affected by
recombination centers-- so
defects, and semiconductors,
and a few other things
that we're going to talk about.
And then this is almost
limited depending
on what kind of materials
you're using, the mobility,
and so we'll talk
about that, as well.
So what affects lifetime?
We're going to go over,
again, basic recombination
mechanisms in semiconductors.
There's a lot of them.
A lot of them have some rather
complex equations behind them.
We're not going to delve too
deeply into how to derive them.
You're welcome to do that.
It was actually kind
of fun to do on my own
and refresh myself, so
it was really useful--
and also be able to
calculate our excess carrier
concentration, which
we're going to do
in the next couple slides.
So n-- let's say
for n-type material,
the number of mobile electrons
you have is defined as n.
n0 is very frequently
your doping density--
these come up one at a time.
Sorry.
Wrong direction-- are generally
the doping concentration.
So if you're putting
in phosphorus atoms
into your silicon, it
would be the concentration
of phosphorus atoms.
Your delta n is how
many extra electrons
are you adding,
mobile electrons,
due to the photo
excitation of light.
And so that's what
this is saying--
is that you have
some-- your delta n is
equal to your generation rate.
So your generation
rate is generally
in units of carriers
per volume per second--
so how many carries you're
generating in a certain volume.
And because delta n
is actually a density,
you need to say, OK, how
long do those carriers last
once they're excited?
And so it's the g tau product
is what gives you your delta n.
Now, when working with
silicon, it's really important
to understand what the
different ratios are
of n, n0, delta n, the
doping concentrations.
So getting these relative
numbers in your head
is an important step
in moving forward.
So let's say we subject a piece
of silicon to AM1.5 spectra.
So your G-- sorry.
This is a little off.
There we go.
Sorry about that.
When I added some equations--
so your generation rate is
on the order of 10 to the 16th.
A care lifetime for silicon--
this is not a great lifetime,
but an OK one-- is
about 10 microseconds.
And so as a result of
that, you'll get about 10
to the 11th excess carriers
per centimeter cubed.
And if we compare that-- so for
every excess electron we make,
remember we also
leave behind a hole.
So we have delta n is
generally equal to delta p.
And that's about 10 to the 11th.
If we look at our intrinsic
carrier concentration--
so if we had no dopants,
how many carriers
would we have just for
thermal excitation?
And that's about 10 to the 10th.
And so you can see that
delta n is actually
larger than your
intrinsic carrier
concentration for silicon under
normal illumination conditions.
Now, let's take an example.
Suppose we add phosphorus at
the order about 10 to the 16th,
and so that's generally
about what a base doping
concentration should
be-- in that realm.
It might be a
little high, but you
can see that your delta p
is much greater than p0.
So p0 would be how
many holes do you have,
which is a ratio of your
intrinsic carrier squared
over your doping density.
And that's about 10 to the
fourth, so it's way, way
less than what was there
without excitation.
So the number of holes without
any light shining on it is p0.
You generate a bunch
of holes, delta p,
by shining light
on it, and you can
see that these numbers
are drastically different.
And of course,
your doping density
is actually much, much
larger than your delta n.
Your majority carriers
don't change very much,
but your minority carriers
change very, very drastically.
That's really what
this is trying
to say here under excitation.
What is lifetime?
So that bubble
shouldn't be up yet.
So we measure tau by creating
some excess carrier population
and then watch them decay.
And they decay at some
rate, recombination rate,
and under steady
state conditions--
so under constant
illumination, we're
not looking at transients-- your
recombination rate is actually
equal to your generation rate.
So if you compare
the two equations
on the previous slide, they're
true under steady state
conditions.
[INAUDIBLE] going to pop up.
And so your lifetimes add
up like parallel resistors.
So we have tau
bulk, which is kind
of the effective lifetime of
these photo excited carriers.
1 over tau bulk is equal
to 1 over tau radiative,
so this is radiative
recombination.
And this has to do
with-- basically if you
read the Shockley-Queisser
efficiency limit paper,
this is the lifetime that
they assume was limiting.
And for silicon, this is absurd.
This is never ever
the limiting factor.
And a lot of direct band gap
materials-- for those of you
who don't know what that
is, don't worry about it.
That's often the
limiting factor,
and it has to do with
the absorption is always
equal to the emissivity
in a material.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For a direct
band gap material,
radiative recombination
can be an issue,
and I'll talk about
that in a second.
And there's also
another combination
called Auger recombination.
It's not "Oger" like I thought
when I first came here.
It's "O-jay," kind of like--
I don't know-- OJ Simpson,
I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's dominant only under
very high injection conditions
or very high doping density.
So in your emitter layer where
there's really, really high
doping densities,
you're going to have
a lot of Auger recombination.
And the last one is
Shockley-Read-Hall
So these are three guys.
They came up with this kind of
a model for how recombination
happens in defective
materials-- so materials
with levels, electronic
levels, in the mid-gap.
And again, these add
like parallel resistors,
so you're always-- so
if you remember back
to the leaky bucket, these your
leaky buckets for diffusion
length.
You're always limited by your
shortest diffusion length--
or, sorry, your
shortest lifetime.
And this is often your
limiting lifetime--
is your Shockley--Read--Hall
recombination.
AUDIENCE: Is it for silicon
and for [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: For silicon--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
The Shockley-Read-Hall
is the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So radiative
recombination.
So you can probably
guess from the name
that radiative recombination
involves a photon.
The ability to
absorb photons also
means you have the
ability to emit them,
and so silicon, or
many semiconductors,
will emit photons when
you get a recombination
event across the band.
And when that happens, you emit
a photon under equilibrium.
So equilibrium means
no outside excitation.
It doesn't mean steady
state, so this is, let's say,
in the dark.
You get your recombination rate
is equal to your generation
rate, because it's in
thermal equilibrium
with the area around it.
So it's absorbing protons and
emitting them at the same rate.
And this is equal to B.
So some material parameter
times your hole in a
electron concentration.
And again, under
equilibrium conditions,
that's equal to your intrinsic
carrier concentration.
np product is equal
to ni squared.
Now, when you shine
light on it, your n,
which is to n0 plus delta n--
so this is you excited carriers,
your excess carriers.
So your n now increases and
is greater than n sub i,
and your net recombination rate
is determined by this equation
right here.
So B np minus B ni
squared-- so the difference
between your equilibrium
and your now excited carrier
concentrations.
AUDIENCE: I'm not
sure if I missed this.
Is B just a proportionality?
PROFESSOR: It's a
material parameter, yeah.
It depends on-- for
silicon, I forget.
It was on the next slide.
It's 10 to the minus 15th.
I don't know for
other materials,
but I presume that that
would change-- probably
be a lot higher for
other materials.
And it turns out your radiative
recombination lifetimes,
when you plug these numbers in
and you make some assumptions
about what's really small
compared to each other,
you get these equations here.
And again, this is tau is
equal to delta n over R.
And so you get that.
And now if you look
at for silicon,
you get B is about 2 times
10 to the minus 15th.
Your delta n I
put-- n I determined
just was 10 to the 16th--
some doping concentration.
And your radiative lifetime is
incredibly, incredibly long--
about 50 milliseconds.
And if you remember
from before when
I was calculating a
generation rate for silicon,
we used about 10 microseconds.
So this is really, really long.
And so radiative recombination
is very, very slow,
and it's rarely ever
the limiting lifetime
in silicon solar cells.
However, as you
mentioned earlier,
it's actually a big problem
in direct band gap materials.
And if you think of
there's some materials
we actually want a very short
radiative recombination time.
So for example, if you're
trying to make an LED,
you inject carriers
using a voltage
that recombination
emits photons,
and then you get light.
And that's basically
how an LED works.
So now we'll talk a little
about Shockley-Read-Hall
recombinations.
So this is something
that our lab works,
I think, very, very well in.
We do a lot of defects in
semiconductors, specifically
iron.
And so iron is one of
these really, really awful
contaminants in solar cells.
Just a little bit of iron,
I think-- [INAUDIBLE],
correct me if I'm wrong.
I don't remember what
year production this was.
Maybe it was 2009,
but two grams of iron
could contaminate the
entire year supply
of silicon detrimentally.
So that's a lot.
AUDIENCE: I think you
actually calculate
this in your [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, you
do for a single panel,
and it shocked me.
So basically what we're
trying to say here
is that you have
iron atoms and it
can sit in different
areas of your lattice,
but you have these
defects that exist,
and they introduce
different energy levels
within the band gap.
So the outer electrons of iron
can either sit at these sites--
so these blue sites
where they're donors,
or they can create acceptor
states kind of like boron does,
but they're much
higher up into the gap.
And these act as
recombination centers,
and we'll talk about
why that is in a second.
So these trap
levels can interact
with mobile carriers in a
whole bunch of different ways.
They can capture an electron.
That electron can
then sit there.
If there's enough
heat energy, it
might actually get promoted
and jump out of that, and then
which case it wouldn't
have actually decreased
your excess carrier population.
It can also capture holes,
and it can also emit holes.
And there's a bunch of things
that go into these equations
here.
It depends on a lot of the
energy of this trap state.
It depends on the
carrier excitation.
We'll talk about that
in another few slides.
And it also depends
on these-- what
are effective-- I
forget the exact word,
but the effective hole
in electron lifetimes.
And those are limited
by your trap density.
So these can be
thought of-- suppose
they're each-- let's say
each iron atom is introducing
one trap level.
It would be the number of trap
levels, the density of trap
levels within your system,
times some thermal energy,
and then a capture
cross section,
which is saying, OK, that trap
state exists in one location.
How much area can it see in
terms of what effective area is
it capturing electrons?
And oftentimes under the
right conditions-- so
with very, very deep
traps, so traps mid-gap
under low injections,
your Shockley-Read-Hall
recombination is actually
one of those two lifetimes,
and it's a very simple equation.
And under very, very high
injection conditions,
it's actually summing
them up, and if you
look in the previous
slide, if you
go to delta n goes
to infinity, you
can see that this becomes true.
Joel?
AUDIENCE: The energy,
the thermal energy type
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
That would be my guess.
Sorry, there's another
question back there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so is iron
worse or is gold worse?
PROFESSOR: I can't hear you.
AUDIENCE: Is iron a
worse dopant, or is gold
your worst dopant in
terms of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, in terms
of capture cross section?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I know they're
both bad, really bad.
[INAUDIBLE], do you know that
off the top of your head?
AUDIENCE: Sure, so gold
has a larger lifetime
impact at lower
concentrations than iron,
but it's perhaps one
of worst, and that's
why you're not allowed to wear
gold jewelry at the cleaners.
They ask you to take off your
wedding bands and other jewelry
before entering the
[INAUDIBLE] cleaners.
PROFESSOR: So no
bling in the cleaner.
There you go.
And so for the material
scientists and physicists
in the room, if that does not
apply to you, don't worry.
This is just to explain
what is going on.
Often when you
want recombination
to happen-- so this is a
momentum, or k, versus energy--
it requires not only the
emission of a photon,
but also a phonon to
change its momentum.
When you introduce a trap level,
or these localized impurities,
because it's localized
in real space,
it's delocalized
in k space, so you
have this kind of
flat level in k,
and you have these very,
very efficient pathways
for recombination.
If that doesn't
resonate with you,
don't worry about it right now.
So here we see that
really the impurities can
have a very, very large effect.
If you think of the doping
densities that we put in,
we've been using
about 10 to the 15th,
10 to the 16th for
our doping density.
This is on the order
of like a million less,
and it can have a huge
impact on lifetime.
So one of the worst, again,
as we said, was iron,
and these interstitial
irons are especially bad.
And at 10 to the-- I
don't know-- looks like 10
to the 11th.
Very, very low concentration.
That's one in 10 to the 12th.
So that's one in
a trillion atoms
are iron-- cane detrimentally
impact your solar cell.
So that's really, really bad.
So keeping fabs
clean-- so again,
no jewelry and other
things can really--
that can actually have a very
large effect on your device
performance.
And if you plot that versus
your dislocation density,
you can see that
if you have-- it's
especially bad for very,
very high lifetime silicon.
Just a few dislocations
can actually really, really
hurt it, but the
effect is mitigated
if you're already starting
with very low lifetime silicon.
And again, this is something our
lab works on quite extensively.
It's not just the
number of iron atoms.
So if you take a
piece of silicon,
and you want to
know its lifetime
or how iron impacts
its lifetime,
it's not just the total
number of iron atoms in it.
It's also how
they're distributed.
So if you have, let's say,
clusters of iron atoms, that
would count as one defect,
or effectively less
than the number of atoms in it.
And so clustering these things
can actually be really, really
a good way of cleaning up
your solar cell material,
and this is an effect
called gettering.
And if you can getter
these impurity atoms
into one location, they'll
have less of a detrimental
impact on your material.
So this is kind of a
tricky one to explain,
but this is-- so
Shockley-Read-Hall
recombination can also
show up in something
called service recombination.
So if you look at
your silicon lattice,
each silicon atom has
four valence electrons,
and it bonds to four
silicon atoms around it,
and it has satisfied
covalent bonds.
So this silicon atom has all its
satisfied, all its satisfied,
until you get to the surface.
And at the surface, you have
what are called dangling bonds.
And these dealing
bonds can actually
introduce traps
states, and so you
can see that actually
introduces a whole ton of levels
within the band gap
that can provide
Shockley-Read-Hall
recall recombination
pathways for your carriers.
And so surfaces are incredibly
important, and the way
we tend to think
of it-- and this
is a concept that might be
difficult to grasp at first,
but it scales with two things.
There's two things going on.
You can think of that this
is the width of your cell,
and you have some service
recombination velocity,
which is some kind of
characteristic of how well they
can recombine at the surface.
And at let's say infinite
surface recombination
velocities, it means that any
carrier that comes and hits
that surface will
most surely recombine.
So this drops to zero.
So then you're limited by,
OK, how well can they actually
diffuse to your surface?
So it's again some kind of
ratio of your self thickness
squared over the diffusivity,
your carrier diffusivity,
and that that gives
you an idea of what
your limiting factors are.
So under very low surface
recombination velocities,
you're limited by
this term here,
the first one, and then
the very high ones,
you're limited by this term.
And do there's two
effects going on there.
And it's summarized
as well here.
At very, very low surface
recombination velocities,
your tau surface almost goes
to infinity-- very high.
And you can passivate
these bonds using hydrogen.
So for example, if you use
hydrofluoric acid, what it does
is it etches away the silicon
oxide layer that sits there,
and you have these hydrogen
atoms that now sit and satisfy
these bonds.
And if they're
perfectly satisfied,
you'll have a mobile carrier.
It'll actually elastically
scatter off, not
lose any energy, and not
recombine through these trap
states.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
I thought [INAUDIBLE] is
a very good passivation
barrier for silicon?
PROFESSOR: What is?
AUDIENCE: I thought
silicon dioxide
is a really good passivation
barrier for silicon.
PROFESSOR: I've seen some
diagrams of what silicon
oxide looks like on silicon.
It passivates many of the bonds.
You're absolutely right.
HF is actually
probably the best.
The problem is that it etches
glass and other things that
are in your source material,
and it's incredibly dangerous.
It can kill you
rather dramatically.
So it's only used in
laboratory settings.
If you're trying to actually
take lifetime measurements
and negate the effect of
surface recombination,
silicon oxide can be a good one.
If you actually look
at the structure,
there's a few dangling
bonds in there,
but it can passivate most of
them-- just not all of them.
Another good
passivation technique
is actually the silicon
nitride ARC coating.
That passivates the
surface very well.
So yeah, good question.
There's other ways to mitigate
surface recombination, as well,
and we'll talk about that, I
think, in either next lecture
or the one after that.
So yeah, this slide
is just telling us
that, if we vary our
thickness of our silicon,
we can actually measure our
surface recombination velocity,
and we can fit it
so we can figure out
our tau surface, which is
a really important material
parameter.
Generally, I think good surface
recombination velocities are
anywhere from like 10 to maybe
in the 100ths for centimeters
per second, and really bad
ones are much, much higher.
And the last type of
recombination mechanism
we're going to talk about
today is Auger recombination,
and this looks like--
when I first saw this,
I'm like, why on earth
would this ever happen?
And the fact is it does
until you get to very, very
high carrier concentration.
So you can see that it
involves three particles.
Let's say an n-type silicon.
It needs two
electrons in the hole.
What happens is that you get
the simultaneous relaxation
and excitation.
So you get this relaxation
of this excited electron
into a hole, and then
you get this excitation
of this other electron
into a higher energy state,
and then it thermalizes
down and releases a phonon,
releases heat.
Yeah, Jessica?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
terms of p-type here?
PROFESSOR: So this is going
to be our n-type material.
And again, because this
type of recombination event
requires two particles,
it requires two electrons,
so it's n squared in one hole.
So the recombination
rate goes up
with pn squared at high
enough concentrations.
And so your tau goes out
with the 1 over n squared.
And this is
particularly bad, again,
only at very--
because it goes up
with the square of the
carrier concentration,
it's really bad at very
high carrier concentrations.
So if we look at this plot, we
can see that our minority care
lifetime drops well below
a microsecond around 10
to the 18th, so
you generally want
to stay out of that range
of doping concentrations
in your base, because you'll
have very, very bad lifetimes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
are both sides--
is that the top blue part and
the bottom blue part n-type?
PROFESSOR: I didn't label this.
You're right.
This is the valence band.
That's the conduction band.
And so this is kind of
driving home, again,
that leaky bucket
idea-- that is,
you're really limited
by your worst lifetime.
And so if you remember,
we're thinking
about parallel circuits here.
Your bulk, or your effective
lifetime of each carrier,
is determined by these
three here-- your radiative.
Sorry, that should
be tau band, which
is the same as your
radiative recombination--
Auger and Shockley-Read-Hall.
And so at different excess
carrier densities-- so
we're varying delta n by shining
various intensities of light.
And we can kind of activate
different limiting lifetimes.
So at very low, you're
limited by Shockley-Read-Hall.
And Shockley-Read-Hall
can actually
go down with higher
illumination conditions.
And your Auger, remember
it gets really, really bad
around 10 to the 18th--
becomes your limiting.
So your tau bulk is
never doing better
than your worst lifetime.
AUDIENCE: So on
that graph is tau
and emitter also
the same thing as--
PROFESSOR: Tau Auger?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
tau [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This came out of
Daniel McDonald's thesis.
Tau emitter-- it's
complicated because it
has other influences in it.
Auger, I always think
of recombination
in the emitter as
Auger, but you also
have other carriers coming
in due to injection currents.
And so your excess
carrier population
is also a function of
that, and so the equation
for it gets a little
more complicated,
but it would make sense that,
as you increase illumination,
you're increasing your
current into the emitter.
And you would get more
carriers, and it would decrease.
And it looks almost exactly like
Auger in his regime over here.
I'm not sure of the other
things that go into it,
but if you look up
his thesis, I think
it gives a pretty
good description.
So you're probably bored
of hearing me say this,
but again, we're always
limited by our weakest.
So in defect mitigated
recombination materials-- so
where your shortest
lifetime is due to some kind
of Shockley-Read-Hall
recombination.
Your lifetime for
Shockley-Read-Hall
is always going to
be much, much shorter
than your radiative
lifetimes, which
is a characteristic we
can exploit for measuring
the lifetimes of our materials.
So because very, very few
carriers will actually
radiatively recombine and emit
a photon, that, if more of them
are radiatively
recombining, then we
know that it's a very
high lifetime material.
If there's a lot
of defects and we
have very, very short
lifetimes, very few of them
will radiatively recombine.
And so this emission of photons
with energy at the band gap
can give us an idea of the
lifetime within our material,
and that's how we measure.
It's a technique called
photoluminescence,
and what you do is
you shine light on it,
generally with a laser.
We put a diffuser in
front of the lasers
so the laser beam spreads its
photons over a large area.
We excite all these carriers.
So this laser has very,
very short wavelengths,
and I think in our--
well, very short.
It's 900 nanometers.
Silicon's band gap corresponds
to about 1,108 nanometers.
And so 900 is easily
absorbed, not just right
near the emitter, but
also somewhat well deep
below the junction as well.
And then as you begin
to see recombination,
when radiative recombination
happens, we emit a photon.
And that can happen in certain
areas better than others,
and a lot of it
depends on, like I
said, defect density and other
lifetime eliminating defects.
And it's a good way to
spatially locate where problems
are in your solar cell.
Any other questions?
Ben?
AUDIENCE: How good is spatial
resolution on [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It depends
on your camera.
So we use, I think, a germanium
camera to detect those photons,
because Silicon won't
have a very good response.
And it depends on the CCD
array within your camera.
It can be really good.
I do a similar technique
to measure shunts,
and we have microscope
objectively.
We just have to zoom
in really, really far,
and then we just
scan over an area.
And last little thing is
that, if you recall-- hold on.
Let me-- this slide.
Traps cannot only
trap an electron,
but you can also
emit an electron,
assuming it has
enough thermal energy,
and you can see
that on this plot.
And so this is an
Arrhenius plot.
So again, high temperatures
are in this direction.
Low temperatures are over here.
And you can see that
your lifetime actually
increases at higher
temperatures because electrons
that see that trap fall into
it, then can easily come back
out of it because they
have enough thermal energy
to escape.
And that's really what
this is depicting.
So one of the things I think
for researchers in the room who
are studying these types of
materials, varying temperature
is often a really,
really good way
of looking at electronic
structure materials.
And it can be very,
very powerful,
and this is one
example of a tool
to look at these types of traps.
Oh, good.
We have plenty of time.
We actually might end early.
So now we're going to
talk about mobility.
We've given a lot of-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering, is it
possible to somehow introduce
defects that are at the energy
levels [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
So phosphorus actually has, if
you draw it on an e versus x
diagram-- so if we have
our conduction band here,
our valence band here,
we said iron puts states
in the middle of the gap.
Phosphorus and boron actually
put states very, very, very
close to the valence
band and conduction band.
If you go to low enough
temperature-- so let's
say a below 100 Kelvin--
you can actually
freeze out those donor electrons
onto the phosphorus atoms.
And below certain concentrations
of phosphorus atoms,
for example-- so below like
10 to the 18th-- at 0 Kelvin,
you cannot conduct electricity.
It actually becomes
a total insulator.
That's an excellent question.
But at room temperature,
when kt is on the order--
so kt is your thermal energy,
and at room temperature,
if you put that
for electrons, it's
0.026 electron volts or
26 millielectron volts.
This is a good number to
have in mind, by the way.
When that number is on
the order of this binding
energy for phosphorus,
they're almost always
fully ionized and free, but
that's a very good question.
Anyone else?
So if we remember our
definition mobility
is related to or diffusivity,
and again, our mobility
is saying how well these
excited charges can move around.
And it's related to
how much thermal energy
these charges have, so that's
why we have this kbt factor.
And what's plotted
on the right is
the Shockley-Queisser efficiency
limit, which are the stars.
And then how if you-- let's say
you reduce your mobility by,
let's say, a factor
of 10 or 100.
What's the impact on
the overall efficiency?
And you can see that,
if you detrimentally
impact your mobility,
you can really
have a large effect on
your diffusion length,
and it can really hurt
your device performance.
So it's a really important
material parameter
to think about.
So there's lots of ways that
these mobile electrons can
do what's called scattering.
So if I'm a mobile
electron, I'm moving down
through the silicon lattice.
And let's say I see a
defect, and this defect,
because it has these
extra electrons,
it creates this kind
of area of charge.
It can see that it can scatter
off of it and lose its energy,
and so that's called
a scattering event.
Not really lose its energy.
Sorry.
It'll change direction.
It kind of impacts the
movement of that carrier.
And there's all sorts of other
defects scattering mechanisms.
You can also scatter with an
oscillating atom or a phonon.
There's another type of
scattering mechanism,
and it's heavily
dependent on what
you put into your
material, and we'll
talk about that in a second.
And for a lot of
materials that are,
let's say, porous or amorphous
in some way, or even a lot of,
let's say, organic
semiconductors,
having a good percolation
network is really important
to transport these charges.
And often it's a very
limiting factor in,
let's say, like
organic photovoltaics.
And so this is a relatively
simple scattering mechanism.
What time-- oh, we
have plenty time.
What's going on
here is that we can
see that, as we add carriers--
so this is n is 10 to 14th.
Very, very low
concentration of dopants--
as we increase the
number carriers,
are scattering off of
those ionized impurities.
So every time you add
a phosphorus atom,
lets say, you introduce
a static positive charge
and a mobile negative charge
when that electron leaves.
And so you now have
all of these scattering
centers of positive charge.
And so as you increase
the number of dopants--
this for silicon-- you decrease
the mobility of your material,
and it's also greatly a
function of temperature.
I think that's mostly due to
either phonon scattering--
is that right?
Is there any other mechanism
I'm missing, [INAUDIBLE],
if you're still there?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I was on mute.
Yes, I think you're good so far.
We'll keep it simple, and
use the simplest case first.
I think that makes [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But importantly is
that higher temperatures, you
generally get a much
lower, lower mobility.
And again, hitting
home for-- this
is not true necessarily
for silicon,
but for a lot of these
heterojunction devices--
so for example, organics
have very, very low diffusion
lengths, and a lot of
it's limited by mobility.
And so what you do is you make
these Interdigitated-- what
I would call p and n.
I forget the organic
analogy, but p and n layers
that interdigitated
so that they only
have to diffuse not the
width of the device,
but the length of those fingers.
So you effectively need a
much shorter diffusion length.
And so this is
talking about some
of those other
different ideas, and--
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry, that was
a heterojunction? [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A heterojunction
is two different materials.
AUDIENCE: OK, what was
the thing you were just
describing with the--
PROFESSOR: That's an
interdigitated pn structure.
Yeah, so what we're
going to be talking about
is the product of n and mu.
And if you recall that your
conductivity-- so hold on.
Let's go back.
What we have here
is that we have
a highly doped semiconductor.
So this is about 10 to
the 16th, and then we
have our intrinsic silicon.
So this has no dopants
in it whatsoever.
And now, you remember
from last lecture
when we applied a voltage
across the terminals,
a current started to flow,
and when we heated it up,
what had happened?
Who remembers?
AUDIENCE: Current increased.
PROFESSOR: Current
increased, and that's
due to more thermally
excited carriers.
And so your intrinsic carrier
concentration goes up.
And so what was-- for
room temperature, what's
the intrinsic carrier
concentration?
It's about 10 to the
10th-- in that range.
And so in increase-- so a
small increase in temperature
can greatly increase
the intrinsic carrier
concentration-- maybe
something like 10 to the 12th.
Now in a doped
semiconductor, is that
going to affect it as much?
How about you guys think
about that for a little bit.
Mute and talk to your neighbor.
And so I'm going to
heat both of these up,
one with a high
dopant concentration,
and one with a low.
And which one you
think will have
the highest relative change
in connectivity and in which
direction?
So I'll give you three minutes.
So we're now going to subject.
You've seen this demo before.
We're now going to subject our
intrinsic carrier to my hair
dryer.
And right now we're
getting-- let's see.
It's about 10 microamps.
And if we heat this guy
up-- did I mix these two up?
Ah, there we go.
So you can see we get a rather
large increase in current.
That was up to 100
microamps, so a factor of 10.
So quite a large increase.
So let's see a show of hands.
So right now we're
getting-- maybe
we need to put
this on milliamps.
So we're getting about
58 milliamps of current
through the semiconductor.
Who thinks that the current
is going to increase when
we add more thermal carriers?
This is where the doped one.
We just saw the intrinsic.
Do you think it'll go
up, the connectivity?
So this is the
doped semiconductor.
Now who think it's
going to stay the same?
Who thinks it's
going to go down?
All right, so this is split.
Wow.
So right now we're getting about
57 milliamps, and let's heat
this guy up and
see what happens.
And so you can see, it's
actually going down.
It's now 52, 50, 49.
So what's important is that
we're measuring conductivity.
It's not only how
many carriers we have,
but also how well
they can move around.
And it's, again, that
product of number
of carriers times the mobility.
And again, each
of those carriers
carries an electric charge.
So you put the electric charge
of an electron in front of it.
This is what I was supposed
to have up in the background
while that was happening.
AUDIENCE: The intrinsic still
had to go change, right?
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so again, remember
there was huge changes.
One was measuring milliamps.
One was measuring microamps.
So if we look at room
temperature, we have about 10
to the 10th intrinsic carriers.
So this is for intrinsic silicon
with no dopants whatsoever.
As we increase the
heat, I don't think
we're going to 500 degrees,
but let's say we get the 400.
We're only going up by a factor
of 100, which is substantial,
but if we had 10 to
the 16th carriers
originally from our
dopants, these added number
of intrinsic
carriers aren't going
to have really much
of an effect at all
in terms of the connectivity.
So what's really
affecting the dope case
is that our mobility
actually goes down
with temperature due
to the scattering
events with temperature.
And for intrinsic silicon,
you get a little bit better
mobility, so it's a
little bit higher,
but they both have
the same general trend
of lower mobility, but
only by, let's say,
this is about a
factor of 10, where
it was about a factor of 100
for the intrinsic carrier.
So again, our carriers
in the intrinsic case
go up by a factor of 100.
Our mobility goes up
by a factor of 10,
so the conductivity then has
to increase by a factor of 10.
And for our doped
semiconductor, really the heat
is just hurting our
conductivity because
of the decrease in mobility,
and the thermal carriers
don't really add--
they're washed out
by the sea of dopant
atoms that are really
adding all the carriers.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So if you were
to obviously heat up
[INAUDIBLE] more--
[INAUDIBLE] the doped more,
it would probably eventually
get to the intrinsic case
where there are
constant increases,
but would you ever want
your solar cell that hot?
PROFESSOR: Would you ever
you your solar cell that hot?
That's a good question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I don't know
how [INAUDIBLE] would it
melt [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So let's go--
there's an equation for that,
and we'll talk about
that later, too.
So if you look at our VOC,
if we have a large saturation
current, that means that we're
going to have a very low VOC.
We have this reverse
current that's
going in the opposite
direction of our illumination
current that's opposing
that illumination current.
And so if it's large,
then it'll hurt our VOC.
And you can see that it scales
with d, which scales with kt,
and so we get this
increase in temperature
is increasing this J0.
And so for most
types of cells, heat
is very, very bad, especially
for crystalline silicon.
For amorphous silicon,
it's different.
Well, I'm not going to
get into that today,
but for crystalline
silicon, heat is generally
very bad for the performance.
And when you do
testingg-- so for example,
when NREL does testing, they'll
rate all your cells at AM1.5G,
some calibrated solar
simulator that's illuminating
your sample.
And they're kept at
constant temperature,
so the temperature
is always reported,
and it's generally
kept at the 25 C.
So the temperature is a very
important characteristic.
But to answer your
question, if, again, we
looked at an Arrhenius
plot-- so this is 1/kt.
So this is high
temperatures over here,
low temperatures over here.
And this is carrier
concentration.
At very, very high temperatures,
when your thermal carrier--
so if you extend this out
to higher temperatures,
you can see that
this will actually
surpassed the number
of dopant atoms,
and you'll actually increase.
So this is high
temperature over here.
Your carrier concentration
will actually
increase at much, much
higher temperatures,
and this is what's
the extrinsic region.
So your donor concentration
is pretty much only determined
by your dopant
density, so this is ND.
And then at low
enough temperatures--
so this is very low
temperatures-- you actually
start freezing out
you're donor electrons
into these donor states.
So that actually sums it up.
If you guys have
other questions,
feel free to ask
them, but we actually
can end a little bit early.
I do have your homework, so if
you want those, come up here.
And I think [INAUDIBLE]
posted the projects online
so you can finish
homework number three.
That's it.